this is Startalk Taylor from Eugene
Oregon is a do gravitational waves have
any direct effect on the physical
environment for example if an event
causing gravitational waves occurred
close enough to earth would it have any
discernible effect on humans or the
planet well that's a question I can even
answer and in fact if we measured this
event from two black holes and I would
have to start that way which was unfair
fortunately for us 1.2 billion light
years away but had we been let's say
within a few tens of years of that aha
we would have measured something and you
would have measured exactly what we
measure in our detectors you wouldn't
stretched in one dimension and
compressed in the other dimension you
would have felt that now we resist
stretching and compression but our you
know auditory mechanism is designed to
resonate in response do you think that
we could technically hear a
gravitational wave even in the absence
of air that's that's not because it's
saying that's for mommy I don't I think
let's get to that issue right away
because we've we and not you we have
generated some confusion mm-hmm by
saying listening to the universe which
is what a lot of people have said about
this and it's true but it's nothing it's
not necessarily a sound wave that's
exciting us I see and what is happening
is that we are seeing these stretchings
and compressions and that's certainly
going on in your ear to the compression
is exciting even for that one mile one
one year away light year away it's still
too small for you do you got close
enough you would feel to over your whole
body then you might hear something but
that's not where we're doing but we're
doing a sound wave is like the
compression and expansion of the air
around you that's right this is the
actual space itself is doing yeah but
but be careful what it is a space that
you're right space is doing expansion
and the compression on the other hand
our instruments this is where it gets
converted into sound that's why I looked
at your microphone is that what we do is
we have a device that measures these
very tiny displacements we're using
light and the timing of light but then
we convert that into a sound by
amplifying
and then that gets put into a
loudspeaker yes and then it makes a
sound look the important out like an
electric guitar
exactly but exactly like and and the
other thing is that it's an ad with the
other three other piece of it is that
this phenomena though these phenomenons
we're seeing a phenomena we're seeing
are things that have the frequency of
our order of our auditory system that's
the nature is making things with
frequencies that run from the bottom of
the piano to the top of the piano and
that's just by chance that you that's
because the things we're looking at well
it's a little more than that what it is
is our instruments only sensitive in
that band okay and on top of that nature
is kind enough to give us something that
does it's wiggling and expanding and
contracting and accelerating in that
frequency band a couple of black holes
collide they have inter ring space time
in the human auditory figoratti so like
that okay so it's not sound waves
traveling through space I just don't
want to have that like an electric
guitar string it's not sound wonderful
analogy for people you had to build LIGO
to build the body of the guitar so you
could record the shape absolutely of the
way that's a beautiful note excellent
and then we're going to all break out
into a hairstyle guitar